you
hey guys we're Callie and Miguel we're
playing white day a labyrinth named
school which the Caribbean horror game
we're very excited to check it out but
you know a little bit more about what
this is well this is a ps4 version of an
enhanced port of a game that has come
out in PC I believe and a number of
mobile devices and this is due to come
out on PlayStation 4 in August this is a
first-person survival horror game based
in a very cursed school and you play a
boy who is trapped in the school and
they believe he's trying to help three
girls
also trying to escape we're going in
relatively blind I could have read a
little bit more about this but in a way
yeah so let's do this just you know
we're live now or on twitch and YouTube
you can ask us any questions about the
game there we'd love to have you in the
comments so make sure yeah
and for the record I mean I think some
of you guys were curious about the fact
that it is on ps4
there's quick glance at the settings the
game has a very strong element of feng
shui which sort of explains why there's
there's this yin and yang in this adjust
screen brightness screen and we're also
going to be playing it in Korean so with
English subtitles of court yeah for some
reason that yeah then save my settings
so we'll see how that goes oh well um
looks just too normal I like that hell
is one of the options okay alright so
I'm very excited I really like horror if
you know about the Korean um like flash
comic with like where's my baby
which is like look it up you haven't
seen it if you think you can handle
horror that is my jam so I'm very
excited I think I'm gonna get really
freaked out though and I believe this is
white day is named after the gift-giving
traditions started in Japan which
happens a month after Valentine's Day
yes on Valentine's Day in Japan girls
present boys with chocolates and then
different kinds of chocolates symbolize
different things so you can give a
certain kind Chapa to represent like I'm
romantically interested in you or you
can give chocolates to friends and give
different kinds and then white day is a
day for boys traditionally to
reciprocate so I'm wondering what that
has to do with anything aside from the
fact that we already can see that the
protagonist is holding a gift a spooky
gift looks like a box of chocolates a
little unimaginative but it is high
school I remembered I would love
chocolates that was quick
Oh on YouTube your name is a bunch of
letters so I'm sorry I can't pronounce
it but we are playing on ps4 alright
March 13th which is the day before white
day cool cool yoga oh no i'm already
spooked press i want to run through the
crouch crushing realities chance of
getting caught by janitors being caught
by janitors okay running too much will
make you dizzy so make sure take a rest
alright running too much definitely
makes me dizzy hi goob and errol uh I
think I turned some stuff up and down so
let me know if you could hear better go
to homeroom 8 first a different
documents throughout the school cuz
they're pretty typical like
point-and-click style you know walking
through mm-hmm first person horror I
don't like that clock why is that there
if I could turn the dial I don't think
you can do anything I could just think
you just look at it okay but it's
apparently 10 the problem 8 a.m. or p.m.
we do not know you can save the game
using bulletin boards at school a little
hampy 89 on YouTube says this is the
console port of the mobile game because
it is exactly the same character in
graphics as the mobile version
um I believe so it is a console port but
it seems to be a little more you don't
usually find zippers
yeah menus yeah that's interesting it
seems to be a higher fidelity I guess is
what I'm trying to say than a mobile
game
felt-tip pen uh soups gaming this is
called white day a labyrinth called
school
which is like that's how I feel about
school yeah wandering that labyrinth is
very interesting Charlie Brown style
naming convention a labyrinth named
school all right there used to be a
small pond between the main building in
the auditorium they say oh no they say
that the pond was created by a bomb
during the war I'm assuming they mean
Korean War and it had obliterated a
refugee tent that had been pitched there
obviously a view every refugee in the
tent died that's horrible
it was said that the bottom of the pond
was tainted red with their blood
yikes Oh another story about the pond if
you write to your crush asking them to
come to the pond and they show up you'll
live happily ever after with them
because that's what happens at the death
pond okay oh but if your crush doesn't
show up then you'll die so make sure
make sure you pick the right person um
gube says never heard of this where'd
you guys find this one um we had been in
touch with the UK game publisher P cubed
which actually um is a rare publisher
that they're based in the UK they
publish games in UK but they also
publish an NTSC North American version
of their games they're known for root
letter gal gun double peace and the two
Stein gape games steins gate so good
place times gate in fact we're going to
be doing a giveaway later this week on
some of those pqube titles uh yes to
people who are asking what the game is
about it's about a boy trapped in a
haunted school um yeah I knew very
little just because I really wanted to
go into this horror game not knowing a
whole lot so uh um we can't play it be
playing it in Korean we just make it
more confusing um so I'm excited to see
kind of like when things pick up and
when we get a little spooked so here ah
mr. dreadful um I didn't really hear any
of the other names that Miguel was
saying cuz I was so so attached to
steins gate I think it's one of my
favorite anime but there's based on a
visual novels
you should check it out oh we got a text
message uh haunted text message good guy
line four because it a normal text
message or a haunted - out of service
great wait what's okay that's it just a
warning you may not get messages great
okay and the camera is a little
sensitive ooh
okay so it's a fly that Oh goob talking
about Galligan yeah um all right this is
clearly the tutorial section of this
game so we're learning how to use some
of these you know doors and things
because who knows how to use this oh yes
and pqube also published one at least
one of the Guilty Gear games so we are
going to be able to get will be giving
away that as well later this week
Errol says I already got I'm gonna romp
up one to reload Callie if you keep
telling me to buy games I'll never get
through my back oh I was so touched
Duncan rump was great too but if you if
you like that then I would suggest
trying steins gate it's different but it
is a very good time travel story like
one of my favorite time travel stories
so oh so you have to use the felt tip
pens to save your game okay huh mmm I
don't like this room oh it's a bathroom
why are 30 lights in here freaked you
out
no bathrooms have had a long history in
horror games
no um slow oh oh are you hiding guess oh
I didn't know there was like I stopped
you I didn't know there was a hide
option I guess you just like walk in ah
this reflection scared me a little hairs
person yeah mirror animations I'm so
lame at least his legs don't like aim in
a different direction that would be
creepier yeah well that's that's very
cool a stall
also normal do we know where we going
I need find a key oh I bet it's in the
teachers lounge see if we can actually
get there I don't actually know that I
Justin I I would assume you really
looked at this and received the school
magazine homeroom sex okay I got that
get to homeroom six and homeroom eight
hmm all right okay um that's a bathroom
it's a boy's bathroom oh you were just
in the girls bathroom it's okay I mean I
guess it makes sense cuz there were no
urinals in the which typically there
aren't all right all right no keys mmm
the sinks are outside the what the
bathroom sinks are outside the bathrooms
okay I would go the other direction
Errol says you guys have any funny high
school stories to share since we were in
one after all um four years I'd like to
think we we would when I was a junior
the senior prank was to superglue all
the lock shut and I couldn't go to
chemistry and it was awesome that's the
coolest story I have because high school
sucks
see oh no
okay oh geez
pop-ups scary huh okay I've been waiting
for something to happen it's all right
looks like our health items a good
instant lunchbox coffee soymilk
tranquilizer
of course tranquilizer and coffee for
sake kid you know you need the
stimulants and you need the depressants
that's how that works
um high school let's see uh
I had a band Locker my senior year and I
had tons of space I don't I don't have
anything interesting I I did some drama
by never joined any of the drama classes
I would perform in prowl what they
called brown bag concerts in our
courtyard in lunch time and I would
perform kids in the hall skits with
friends some of whom were actually in
the drama club and classes I did drama
for many years I didn't do it in high
school because I didn't want people to
know I was a nerd so I just didn't take
one time I was babysitting and I'd taken
my DS to babysit in my backpack with my
homework so when I was done with my
homework I could play my ideas and the
next day I hadn't taken my D s out of my
backpack and I like go to put my books
in my locker and I freaked out I was
like everyone's gonna find out my secret
and I like shoved it in the back of my
locker and now I work in video games so
everybody knows I was 30 years old I
believe now I was 29 years old when the
Dia's came out yeah press f to pay
respects if I know that's what I say
instead of rip now not really a note
from the class president because of you
the chemical solvent was taken from me
by the teacher I think that sounds like
a that's what a high schooler would
saying the chemical solvent was taken
from me by the teacher I think he's mad
about that time you were fooling around
and spilled it all over the garden and
killed the trees what am I supposed to
do now I have chemistry
tomorrow you have to take care of this
all right
no I don't oh my gosh the UH this really
that was a person outside vote was the
clock
this really is an alpha because the my
camera settings got resetted this is an
alpha build um one sec I am an inverter
yeah yeah deal that's the scariest parts
alone I think there's some what finally
finally as of March 9th the installation
of a light fixture next to the workshop
is scheduled to be completed by tomorrow
bla bla bla bla bla bla okay oh now you
can go [ __ ] sorry we're all out of swear
okay well dokey okey doke let's G oh
they don't seem haunted yeah so what
hope she's not been I mean no he doesn't
know girl on the right looks sassy Errol
just said I'm expecting a creepy lady to
come out like that one jump scared
Karine comic let's talk about that the
beginning of the stream
that's that comic messed me up it's so
scary like you could you could literally
oh alright you guys scared me too okay
let's just be honest uh that comic you
could just Google that one Korean horror
comic and you'll find it it's horrible
this game kind of reminds me of this
anime called another just basically
final destination the anime oh is that
right when'd that come out I want to say
2011 but that's probably wrong why
should beat us all flirty this one ya
know dis oily tongue yeah
oh that was the wrong thing to say
that's great and you meet a girl and
you're like oh do you know are you
friends with this girl everyone thinks
is hot uh I mean we already made her mad
let's just be me okay yeah matter you
shouldn't matter
yeah it's gonna eat you know don't
bloody have a song why should I help you
alright we're going to mean root area
the renegade root OD fire 5 says 2012
for another thank you
oh yeah J Chan says it reminds me of
Corpse Party which is on sale on Steam
right now if you want more anime games I
did a nice list of all the best anime
sales on Steam on GameSpot um I feel
like somebody asked what game this was
this is white day what the heck a
labyrinth called school I don't care
about this girl I don't want to help her
okay these are really weird this is a
very weird way to like explore objects I
think
jaysean this is for ps4 we are playing
on ps4 currently but it's also a mobile
game oh she wants us to go to the girls
bathroom
we were just they were just then we were
also pretty thorough I mean I'm sure
there's something new there but there's
also a shiny object to your left
yes that you should pick up first ah
wire-cutters
goob is right I do like dunking around
for a lot I'm slowly converting everyone
I know to it just the other day I had
Kelly explain the whole concept of it
the homicidal bear and all these murder
trials yeah um I think you should go to
the wait no there's something gleaming
it's a note is it another construction
note no I don't care I don't care I okay
let's go to the girls bathroom cuz
clearly clearly something's different
there ooh I wonder if you can buy coffee
look there's curry in the machine and at
the mommy
that's edamame right uh it looks like a
demonic okay dry bread company hot and
cold food casual food um J Chen this is
about a guy who's trapped in a haunted
question work school um and it's like a
Korean a survival horror game
it's a weird-looking tree um
[Music]
ooh goop wants a wrap up on the Dungan
rump a timeline before three comes out
well I could certainly help
oh god this girl's we I don't like her
we go creepy music
y'all don't you to tell me D yeah it's
our first time yeah it was really our
for me so what just what kind of help do
you need in here why is she I hate her
door oka kokichi dishes she recommend go
step a certain day Tom don't you will go
home
pretty do it ah oh you go to Nicolas
girls evil yo system khatola she doesn't
need to look so evil she's really
smaller this table we did a lot of whoop
don't sound so surprised ok I guess we
got to say yes cool no collected at us
though is she try to be flirty to get us
to do something for her well let's hide
her student we'll be glad to do that
I don't think so she isn't she's flirty
poses oh yeah she's like credit in then
please help me
it's awfully demanding I kind of gloss
over that that's ok did I just climb him
there's like a that's apparently you're
very tall
oh okay we need to get the ladder from
the construction area Thank You D fire
five thank you
B fire thank you is what she said when
we zoomed past it cuz we were busy
hating her uh oh no the clock is going
off that's new it's been we've been here
for four hours now you remember the time
because I wasn't awake no I'm an idiot I
was looking at the minute-hand we've
been here for 20 minutes we have kind of
yeah we literally have for 20 minutes
I'm great at telling time I passed
kindergarten even better at math I mean
this oh sorry
everyone okay I don't hear myself on
them Mike we okay okay everyone I can't
hear I can't hear me on the headphones
no work yeah I think goop says wrestled
um anyway if you're just joining us this
is why a a labyrinth called school
Korean horror game we're on twitch and
YouTube you can ask any questions and
chat with us and hang out we're playing
half-life 3 instead of a wrench or a
pipe yeah we got lighter eric says we're
fine we can he can hear us we're all
good yes our oh my god I hate this girl
[Laughter]
Nick you argue chew Miguel what what
what does Gucci mean that means we're
good okay all right
oh no he was I'm not I'm not keen on
young kids slang these days okay
yikes
I don't have any of my audio by the way
you're not supposed to okay all right
uh so we all had a day like this right
gosh I hope not
I mean well oh wait here's another area
I like this trick question about the
mileage a while they're at a appears yes
sorry I think the jumpscared disc it
loosened the cable I can hear now oh I
can't hear myself but apparently
everyone else can so we're good or not
hot steam okay I think we're good just
too too spooky for the mics thank you
today thank you um some puzzles need to
be solved using a cursor you can work on
an area when the cursor changes have all
routes um puzzles Errol's making
paranoia agent comparisons now just
loving this I love that anytime I I'm on
a stream you talk about anime even
though this Korean love it
have you seen um the wailing it's this
Korean horror film that's like I think
from last year yeah was about it's about
uh that's a hard thing to answer it's
very long it's more it doesn't have like
jump scares it's just kind of haunting
and creepy it's basically about the
devil occupying a whale not a way
whaling is in like W ail whale
all right close the valve close to
valves so I like to think I'll be able
to get past that area
oh we did need the wire cutters
glad I lied I don't need to go down
Advan Tori I got out in front of that
again okay what you know just so can I
do a quick seance in here we set off an
alarm
whoa okay I think we're gonna do some
alchemy that's what it looks like to me
aha okay I guess we have to play around
with connectors here I'm turning every
oh I see
right okay oh we got okay
let me know if I'm moving this stuff too
quickly I don't we're gonna get three to
light up not exactly sure what just
happens like Owen saves throw stuff at
you
metal token oh it has the metal symbol
and it gives off a lucky vibe home at
classroom key I didn't take home a
canned that's why I don't know how to
cook
I wasn't they didn't offer home make in
my school I took Molly Ewan instead oh
yeah I remember Model UN I didn't take
Model UN though and then I took a
creative writing and journalism tell me
tell me about your math classes because
you and uh Alex new house new house did
some pretty awesome math in during e3 uh
yeah I went all the way through uh your
one calculus mmm so and then I ended up
being a writer so whatever
what was that giggle I hate you come on
see nothing bad god she's like shut up
use your real voice next time do it on
your own
Phish song yeah no one likes it whatever
you are Candido crew Gaara
yo yo yo yo yo Suns on tape I wanna see
a man's arm do your thing you guys oh oh
oh I hate this girl oh you're not cute
you're not funny
don't you watch tsunami on come down you
wanna
kunavaram young it was a night fifty
years ago come tonight quite like this
shut up
Egon doctor yeah yochanan so to me or
onna bonds oka Nagi honey Dynamis I
don't know why I hate her cuz this is
the exact anime archetype always loved
oh I'm like yeah tell him what's up but
why you Blair witching right now I don't
trust her
that's why I don't like her I don't
trust this archetype in a horror game
uh-huh
Errol says watch her get kidnapped by a
ghost or something and then it's
mandatory to save her not she's not good
I just knock I'm not gonna keep playing
just stand in the corner like that being
weird
again if you're just joining us this is
white day labyrinth called school Korean
horror game that we're checking out you
can chat with us in the YouTube chat
twitch chat and those are the two chats
Ike said it like there were three this
is coming out in August whoa okay okay
you know when the janitor chases you
right they were talking about janitor
chasing me but I'm not even playing this
is a cutscene that would have been
scarier if it were just you and are
decapitated okay this girl liked this
girl I like her already
you can trust her she has glasses
Oh goop I didn't include games boxes we
don't get that chat here so I wouldn't
be able to risk on i'm a boudreaux hyung
see i just go home to initial to him i
union home tornado there's a difference
between getting angry and putting a kid
with a baseball bat yeah exactly
thank you okay
oh man Jekyll and Hyde janitor Don't
Tell next thing like gee you're a
transfer student this is so anime let's
see man who is this girl that we keep
asking people about so young uns oh man
this [ __ ] man Sarge any degree done he
mean Betty Kundun on you she gonna have
wings you can trust the the Megan egg in
any anime that's Nick Nick Nick
margarita says OMG that Miguel scream
has us dying out me off great today
great um I would like to clarify this is
not a Japanese games is Korean ticking
all these anime archetype boxes
tell her I got you we got her I'm sorry
I was busy I'm busy looking at the chat
I wasn't you know sure what she was
talking about okay
I don't know what she's talking about
but I want to protect her you'll make
more city she's probably the villain
she's probably a ghost now yeah yeah you
didn't see those on the way in I did but
yeah other spots see while he's on
patrol he'll chase after you if you run
or turn on the light to chance to
increase we'll be careful
Oh switch gotta be sneaky this doesn't
sound like fun
freakin what exactly are we doing I
can't see anything it's too dark
Errol's is what if you're the goes could
be let's turn the twist to end all
twists the janitor will catch you did
she say like snatch everything right and
then turn off the light turn off the
light weight goes to tree ooh another
notice for maintenance
who cares is that key to this drawer a
fine a weight you know we see that
horror game five grand wait so the
janitor hates the light being on right
he just knows you're in there for lights
on anything because the can we get into
this drawer enough I opened it I don't
see anything oh wait no the one with the
red key icon cuz you just picked up a
key see I turned little like oh my god
this baby you have a cell phone use the
life of your cell phone not you I'm
talking about the character
I find it interesting that what's that
sound I think it was okay um I find it
interesting that the villain of this
game is the janitor when we literally
saw a ghost lady earlier so one goes so
far
all right Ben the official ghost count
is one
down the slide lock lock
hmm you could tell how old the original
is because the computers
oh yeah CRTs do you know what our our
mission is here because if there's
nothing we need then we might as well oh
that's what the edamame look in boxes
it's soy milk oh that's not the taste I
want to be thinking of when I drink soy
milk though
mockingjay how do you find what
who just displays their uniforms like
that oh okay I'm okay
good good I'm good all right better than
that last ghost she got a text about
your scream also oh come on
oh hey or at the end no we're at the end
of the demo term begins August 17th
that's the day after my birthday and I
was warned that this demo was a little
short so we were going to maybe play the
early area again
umm we're already about out of time okay
only two ghosts in that whole demo but
we'll find out more in August that was
white day a labyrinth called school
thank you so much for joining us
wrapping a little bit early because the
demos a little short but I appreciate
everybody's questions always appreciate
the anime chat in streams that I'm on so
you can always tweet at me at in Kido
Chico I nky do ji ka ka Oh talk to me
more about animating Miguel where the
cam they find you I am normal mode on
Twitter normal mode much easier than
mine
yeah continue the conversation with us
there that you so much again for joining
we will see you next time